[Music]
Hey Bojack and haven't heard from you in
like three months what's new with me did
I tell you I'm working at a blog you
don't care if people read your work
uh-huh and that's what's so great about
you I
don't know if you heard but mr. peanut
butter is running for governor I am
specifically on the side of the facts
and also on the side of feelings well I
really wish you are here for this all my
life I have one of a family would you
could you with a mouse Wow
also I haven't seen Todd in a while he's
not with you is he I never know if I can
handle anything that's what makes my
life so exciting
this is Diane by the way when obviously
it's funny the last time I saw you you
told me that you needed me in your life
and then you just disappeared anyway
things are even crazier around here
lately
I'm not going to hurt you ever since I
was a baby people always said I look
like Bojack horseman that's the terrible
thing to say to a baby
the world is dark and scary and full of
creepy clown dentists but they gotta
push through and hope there's better
stuff ahead
I'm sure you say something like that's
the dumbest thing I've ever heard
what if you Pam where've you been okay
yeah thanks then she would be so
overwhelmed by the unbearable
ludicrousness of the situation that you
would get in your car and drive to
Hawaii
wherever you are I hope you're happy I
really do Oh jack
[Music]